so I missed it when when Sam asked how
many people have heard of the penny
holder can you guys do that again
awesome that is so cool to see because
if I had asked that question and I'm
room this size two and a half years ago
when he first started scaling the
company I would not have seen nearly
that many hands so today I'm gonna share
with you how we turned what started as a
bootstrap to personal finance blog into
a digital media company with millions of
readers the pending order is a Content
site we help readers earn and make money
in interesting ways and we use
storytelling to do that so we use
storytelling to make personal finance
fun my background is in journalism and
while my data dated now doesn't include
that much writing I am a writer at heart
like many of you how many of you guys
are writers awesome cool so I feel I
feel that with you we got that in common
about six years ago I left mainstream
media to use my content creation skills
in a different way in a more
entrepreneurial way so I launched a
Content agency that helped other
companies grow their blogs and a few
years into that venture we brought on
what we thought was a pretty cool client
called the penny order it was founded by
a guy named pirate Kyle Taylor and over
the next year and a half our
relationship grew when we are creating
more and more content for the site to
the point where Kyle ended up acquiring
my company and bringing in-house myself
several members of our team and our
processes around creating content I also
had a baby around that time so it was a
really busy year when I first started
working with Kyle that was in 2014 and
this is what the website looked like
then very different from what it looks
like now a lot has changed since then as
San mentioned I was the third employee
and we now have more than 80 employees
and actually this week on Tuesday we
announced via a press conference that
we're going to hire more than 160
positions in st. Petersburg Florida over
the next three years
we see about 16 million unique readers
every month and last year we brought in
20 million dollars in revenue
this year we are on track to nearly
double that and because of that growth
the Inc 5000 has named us as the fastest
growing media company in 2016 and again
this year 2017 so how did we go from
what started as really a one-man
personal blog and turn that into a
digital media company today I'm going to
share with you two answers to that
question the first is having mission
driven content and the second is
developing the right processes so you
can scale and create that content my
goal here really is to give you guys
some actionable ideas and strategies
that you can take back with you to grow
your own businesses
anyone here if you're like--you're
your company has a strong mission let's
see a show hands it's a few okay cool so
having a strong mission is really
important especially for a content
driven company because it's gonna help
you better serve your readers and it's
gonna help you keep all of your content
feeling really cohesive but it's also
good for your bottom line because having
a strong mission helps you figure out
what decisions you need to make for your
company and this is our mission to put
more money in our readers pockets and
well I just told you how much has
changed over the last three years well
this is something that hasn't really
changed we've really stayed true to this
mission and it's I guess it's our
guiding star if you will so if you walk
around our halt the halls of our new
office in st. Pete in Florida you will
actually hear people asking this
question does this put more money in our
readers pockets I'll give you a few
examples you will hear this question in
at our editorial meeting so every
morning we have a number of what we call
editorial stand-ups there are quick
meetings where the editors are going
over what content we're going to cover
that day and we might talk about a pizza
deal there's a pizza deal we heard about
you get free pizza is that gonna put
more money in our readers pockets and if
the answer is yes it might be something
we'd cover likewise we might hear about
a woman who figured out a cool way to
make some extra money on the weekend
and maybe she is collecting dog hair
from her around her house and making
money about dog hair that is by the way
a real thing that we have written about
does that help put our more readers and
more money in our readers pockets is
sharing her story and giving the tips of
how she managed to do that is that gonna
help our readers and if the answer is
yes that's something we consider doing
you'll also hear this question in our
advertising meetings so we get
approached by a lot of advertisers who
want to work with us to reach our
readers and they want to they want to
tell our readers about their products or
their services and so our business
employees they might say should we work
with a certain advertiser and this is
the question that they'll ask they'll
ask is this gonna help our readers this
is gonna put more money in our readers
pockets one of our advertisers for
example is lift lift is a driving
service and so when they we first
started thinking about whether we should
work with them this is the question we
had asked is this actually gonna help
our readers to make money so our goal
when you work with advertisers is we're
not asking our readers to spend or
asking them they're helping them to make
or save money because our readers really
trust us right that's that's why this
whole business works they trust us to
give them great information that's gonna
help them in their life so we have to
make sure that when we decide to work
with an advertiser it also meets meets
this threat this threshold and finally
we talked about this on our on our
product team so we're always trying to
think about what new features do we want
to add to the website and we just added
a new feature that is very much in line
with what I'm talking about today
internally we call it money in your
pocket if you go to the website and you
scroll down on any blog post you will
see a bar at the bottom that says does
this article or did this article put
more money in your pocket and the reader
can choose a thumbs up for guess or a
thumbs down for no and what we're
thinking about this this feature we ask
this question is this gonna put more
money in our readers pockets and the
answer is yes because it lets us collect
data that helps us do our jobs better
so when readers answer that question
it's a way for us to get direct feedback
from them and we
use that feedback loop to continue to
feed them the information that they want
they need so having a this this question
around your mission it can it's amazing
if you lean into that how it can help
you make decisions I want to show you
what a mission a good mission looks and
feels like
so this 60-second video it shows you a
number of our staffers and they're
reading notes from our readers so we
often hear from people around the world
who have used penny hoarder information
to make a change in their life and
that's what we're talking about in this
video so have a look I love this website
you guys are amazing
I cannot tell you how much I learned and
the different leads you have provided
that have helped me have helped me it
helped me thanks to you I've been able
to save and make extra cash thank you
the penny hoarder you saved me two
hundred and seventy seven dollars on an
EpiPen wow that's a lot of money just
wanted to say thank you your post on
companies hiring work from home led me
to a great company that I started with
three days ago I have to say thanks to
the penny hoarder just got one hundred
and twenty eight dollars from a
class-action lawsuit nicely done
we just received a settlement check for
almost fifty dollars thanks to the penny
order because of the penny hoarder
I was hired for one of the full time
work from home physicians and just
started working for leaf force love the
penny hoarder thanks so much for sharing
and we love you
[Music]
thank thank you
Thanks thank you come on gracias thank
you thank you
oh that's the first time I've seen that
on the big screen and it gives me boost
goosebumps you notice at the end calf
one of our employees she's actually here
with us today she kind of got choked up
at the end because our employees feel
really passionate about this mission of
helping our readers put more money in
their pockets and I bet that's I guess a
bonus of having a strong mission it will
lead it will drive your business but it
also helps with employee morale and that
means you're gonna be able to retain
your top talent so what is your mission
driven question that's something I want
you guys to think about what question
can you ask at your company that's gonna
help you make decisions and while it's
awesome if you're making decisions the
the leader of the company you also want
to empower your employees to make
decisions so if you have a question that
they can use to make decisions on your
behalf that's that's even better once
you have that question what do you do
with it how do you create how do you
develop the workflow to create amazing
mission driven content that's what we'll
talk about next we do that at the penny
order through process by having a really
defined workflow that helps us create
great content and the example you're
seeing here today this is a really
personal example to me because this is
the process that we used when when my
company was acquired by the penny
hoarder and my company was not purchased
because it was the biggest agency it was
certainly not the most well known the
reason why the penny hoarder was
interested in us was because we had this
really good process that was scaleable
and that we could use to get bigger and
bigger so what you see here this this is
what we started with and this is what
has become the foundation for a growing
editorial department and I'll walk you
through it
we talked about creating an idea and
writing the content and editing the
content at the beginning most of our
content was written so we always thought
about it as an a text with a text
laser-focus after writing we would
optimize
for SEO format and WordPress so that the
post looks great add photography publish
and then promote on social or email
marketing having a process like this
will work will help you will benefit you
no matter how big you are
can I see a show of hands how many
people in this room are one man or one
woman shops who do every piece or almost
every piece of this on your own wow
that's awesome this is a room of
hustlers that's how I started my agency
as well so when you are a one-person
shop your time literally is money having
a process like this that's efficient is
going to help you do things more quickly
and better but it's also good once
you've grown so at the penny order now
we have a number of people for each of
these roles so we have lots of writers
lots of editors an entire SEO department
a PR department social media department
and having a process like this helps all
those people work together so everyone
knows what their role is in the process
and how they can contribute to it just
because you create a great process
doesn't mean you can't change it in fact
you should really change it as you grow
so as you learn as you improve you
should make tweaks to your process and
these are a couple examples of how our
process has changed you see the first
step is different in both of these
examples right and one we now sometimes
start we start the story the idea the
story comes not from a writer
but from other parts other content
creators amongst the company for example
we sometimes do photo essays so one of
our photographers wanted to feature a
work from home mom and what does it
really like to work from home when you
have kids running around it made for
some great photos and it was very
mission driven so she started that story
it started with photos and then she
worked with other members of our team to
add the text and other components and
like was on the right side you see
sometimes now we actually start ideas
from our SEO department so previously we
used to optimize for SEO after the
content was created and now a lot of the
ideas that we execute they
come into us from our SEO folks and our
lead SEO guy he's awesome he has an
editorial background so he's able to
make sure that that content is really
mission driven while also helping us
appear up higher in search results and
I'll give you a quick example he noticed
that we could rank for best cars for
college students and so he suggested
that to the editorial team they ran with
it created a post around it and now that
ranks on the first page of Google so
right now if you're the leader at your
company or a leader in some fashion it's
probably up to you to create these
processes right you're thinking about
what workflow do I need to create but
the real end game is to create a culture
where all of your employees want to
participate there too and they want to
be the ones who are creating the
processes and that's what I'm so proud
about the penny hoarder is we have
really a process dominated culture where
the employees are the ones without being
prompted to say we need a process for
this or we need a better way better
workflow for for this piece and it's
really cool to see that because when
that happens it means that you have
specialists around your company who are
creating the processes for what they do
every day instead of the person at the
top dictating how it should look they
know their job better they know their
job best right and so they can create a
better workflow and a better process for
it it also gets a media buy-in sometimes
it's hard to get employees to want to
follow processes but if they're the ones
who create it they're gonna be really
enthusiastic about following that to a
tee and training others on how to follow
it as well these are some of the tools
that we use to communicate within our
process some of them are probably
familiar to a lot of you guys slacking
was a popular one we use slack to get
out of email for all internal in
communication and a few ways that we
that we use slack to communicate
throughout our process is we have
different channels for each of our
editorial teams so our editorial team we
basically operate like a newsroom we
have teams of writers and editors and
they each have their own channel in
slack where they can talk discuss topics
talk about we're in the process each
post might be what elements it needs
before I can go go live on the site but
we also have company-wide channels so
for example we have a channel that's we
call ideas or anyone across the entire
company can drop in an editorial idea
for content and the editorial team will
we'll have a look and see if it makes
sense to turn that into a story so it
can be half-baked it can be a seed of an
idea it doesn't have to be well thought
out because it might be coming from a
develop or developer or someone who
doesn't isn't really even a primary
content creator but that allows us all
to keep our eyes out for great stories
wherever we are and share that with our
editorial team flow is a task management
tool and I think we probably used flow
in a way that it wasn't really meant to
be used but it has worked for us we
create a task in flow for each story and
because flow is collaborative once once
the writer creates a task for their
story they can tag anyone across any
other department so that person knows
that they can be you they can be
utilized in that story for example a
writer might tag a videographer and say
hey I think there's potential for video
here and it would be the video team's
job to say yes or no it could work but
then they'd know that there's an
opportunity there same if we need a
graphic or if there's a social component
that we can we could loop in so that
helps us all talk to each other
throughout the content creation process
parsley is a Content performance tool
it's similar to Google Analytics but it
is easier for media companies to use so
it's actually created with media
companies in mind which means that if
someone's a writer an editor who doesn't
always isn't used to creating content on
a regular basis I'm sorry isn't used to
looking at data on a regular basis
because they are creating their canta
content they can easily go into parsley
and find what they need the data that
they need to move forward but Google
Analytics is maybe maybe some of you
here have experienced this it's not
always the easiest to use you can't
always find exactly what you're looking
for if you're not used to digging in
there one other cool feature of parsley
that we use a lot is it allows you to
pull
check reports for authors so we have a
writer named Dana and if Dana wanted to
see what all of her how our posts
performed last week she could pull a
report that just includes posts that she
wrote and that's that's harder to
configure in Google Analytics so they
make it really easy for you and we use
that data to close the feedback loop
right so we have this process and every
time we we create content were able to
look at how it performed we're able to
look at the data and then it helps us
figure out how to create more content
going forward and that's what we use
native for as well it's a feedback loop
for us native is a testing tool I think
actually they have a rep here today but
it allows us to test different
variations of the content that we've
created on Facebook before sharing it
with our Facebook page so if we write a
post there's lots of different headlines
we could try lots of different images we
could try we might test different
variations of that piece of content with
a look-alike audience on Facebook and
determine what is the best performer and
then we'd share it on Facebook on our on
our page so that ideally the idea is
then organically it would it will
perform better so all these tools have
helped us really work together as a team
and communicate better throughout the
process we're also big users of Google
Analytics I'm Sarah I'm sorry of Google
Docs Google Analytics - but Google Docs
I love Docs because they're so
collaborative and they let everyone jump
into any piece of content whenever they
need to so what you see right now is
something a piece of our process that we
started way back when and we still use
today it's what we call the editing
funnel and it's simply a list of folders
in Google Docs and we can move posts
within those folders depending on what
step in the process they're in so you
can see we start with step 1 that's when
a post is getting edited it goes on to a
second editor then it gets warm in a
word press and then it's complete and we
did start this funnel with step one by
the way but over time we tweaked that
process and we realized we actually
needed to step 0 because we needed a
place where he could put Docs that
included
ideas and posts that we are getting
ready to assign this works for us
because everyone can see we're in the
process different pieces are so it
really allows for collaboration amongst
the group and finally once you have a
solid process look for ways to innovate
within that process one way that we've
done it at the penny hoarder and this is
I love this is really fun it's through
Sprint's for we call it a sprint I mean
we made that up but it's we call that
internally whenever we have whenever we
want to get a group of people together
and achieve a lot in a short period of
time we call it a sprint so it might be
an hour or two hours we put on
everyone's calendar anyone who's gonna
participate bring different players
together to achieve a common goal and I
remember the first sprint that we ran
was at our old office back when we had
probably twelve employees and we were we
had a lot of content coming through our
funnel we had a lot of writers and we
were working a lot of freelance writers
but we hadn't yet hired enough editors
and so we had a bottleneck where we
needed a bunch of our posts needed
headlines before we could publish them
the way we do headlines at the pending
order is we have a Google Doc and we all
write in lots of different variations of
headlines so we give ourselves freedom
to fail they can be terrible headlines
but the idea is if you write a lot of
them you can go back and choose a few
that you think might work to test
so in this headline sprint we got all
the content creators we had in a room it
was probably half a dozen of us then and
we all worked on the headlines for this
group of posts that we're ready to go
live besides the headline and if you do
that in Google Docs during a sprint the
cool thing is everyone else everyone can
see what they're what everyone else is
doing like you can actually see the
headlines being created and so everyone
learns like you might learn oh this
editor is really good at this piece and
how did he make that work or how did he
use that word in a headline it gives you
ideas you can feed off of each other
it's also really good for training
employees and when you're at a
fast-growing
startup where you're always trying to
train people if you put a new employee
in a sprint they're gonna see how
everyone else operates and it's a rate
great way to kind of get them up to
speed really quickly so in closing I'm
hoping that you can think about how
these things apply to your business what
is your mission and what mission driven
question can you ask at your
organization that's going to help you
create awesome content and finally what
processes can you develop that will make
that content creation possible if you
already have some processes in place
this is a great opportunity to come back
and and redefine them make sure that
they are as strong as they need to be
peel back some layers go a little deeper
create a place where all of your
employees can participate if you do that
well you will put yourself in an awesome
position to successfully achieve your
mission thank you
[Applause]